she was known as the hot naked chick in
Robin Thicke's now denounced 2013
Blurred Lines music video but now more
than a decade later Emily ratakowski has
had some time to reflect on her own
career and life as a sex symbol she
recently released her Memoir my body
where she discusses what her role has
been both as a commodity and as a
statement of feminist empowerment but
before she was a celebrated writer she
was an acclaimed supermodel and actress
and like all celebrities people want to
know what she eats especially for folks
who so effortlessly seem to maintain a
body like this is it a fast metabolism
as she's claimed in interviews or does
she follow a strict La style diet today
we're gonna find out together hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'll be eating like supermodel actress
and author Emily radakowski but as usual
I'll be dressing up Abby style and
turning it into hunger crushing combos
that I actually want to eat but a quick
disclaimer here folks that Emily's diet
was compiled from primary and secondary
sources so I cannot speak to its
accuracy in real life not that it
actually matters of course because I
will only be using these alleged meals
as a template for teaching gentle
nutrition and for inspiring what I
decide to make for myself this is just
what I ate on a random day and is not
meant to be copied or recommended as how
you should eat as always please be to a
registered dietitian about your unique
needs and if you are not already
subscribed here folks guys help a girl
out hit that subscribe button ring that
Bell so you never miss out and follow me
on Instagram and Tick Tock at Abby's
kitchen okay let me pop in here to tell
you about my sponsor Lark so I am making
a real effort to avoid any single-use
Plastics so I've been filling up my Lark
water pitcher and bottle every day at
home so this picture has a built-in
eco-friendly plant-based filter that
removes Trace levels of contaminants
like lead and chlorine the filter lasts
50 longer than traditional filters to
replace more than 450 single-use plastic
bottles per filter it also has a unique
pure V purification technology that
eliminate bacteria it also self-cleans
every six hours by coating the water and
inner surface of the bottle with UVC
light to prevent bacterial growth in the
filter now here in Toronto where I live
our water is safe to drink without a
filter but there can still be elevated
levels of lead and chlorine byproducts
from pipes after treatment but when I'm
traveling or I'm at the cottage this
definitely gives me some extra peace of
mind because honestly country water is a
bit blah also when I'm out and about or
like at work I've made a habit of
filling up my Lark bottle it has the
same revolutionary filtration and pure V
purification technology as my pitcher
but in a portable bottle that I can
easily bring wherever I go it's also
designed to keep water cold for up to 24
hours or hot for 12 hours and replaces
over 300 single-use plastic bottles per
filter so if you're looking to reduce
your alliance on single-use Plastics
Lark is a great place to start so if you
want to give Lark a try you can check
out the link in the description so I'm
actually really excited about this one I
have a little story time about Emily
Ratajkowski so I feel like like seven or
eight years ago my husband and I were in
Northern California we were looking for
for wedding venues for our wedding and
we were staying at this beautiful little
Resort and kind of doing a dinner there
in their restaurant to kind of try out
some of their potential wedding food as
an option and it was literally just me
and my husband in this outdoor
restaurant until Emily Ratajkowski and
her I guess then boyfriend like walked
in and we're sat right beside us and I
knew who she was so I just like started
talking to her I played a cool my
husband on the other hand could not he
is not normally one to be speechless but
he had his like Jaw on the ground
because he was like obsessed with the
Blurred Lines video of the time and he
just couldn't get us together so I did
all the talking but she was great she
was so nice she gave me a million
different recommendations for like where
to eat or where to stay when we went to
LA or different areas of California so
yeah she seemed like a pretty chill girl
uh now in retrospect I feel like I wish
I looked intently at what she ordered
but anyways I'm hoping my sources here
are just as good as my own eyes in that
restaurant that one time all right
speaking
take a look here at what she has for
breakfast do you have for breakfast
black coffee and granola yogurt maybe
toast I love this for her
um mainly because there's actually
coffee involved and I feel like a lot of
LA socialites are always against coffee
are always trying to like replace it
with something quote unquote healthier I
don't have time for any of that I just
want my coffee I can't drink it black
like Emily obviously that's just like
for psychopaths just kidding you guys
know the drill have your coffee how you
like it all coffee is good coffee in my
books but I will enjoy it my way oh
coffee let me count the ways I love you
one two three four the mom and me loves
that it gives me life while the science
nerd in me loves it it's probably one of
the most well-studied edible substances
on the planet we love a good science
moment we have good evidence that coffee
may help to support beneficial gut
bacteria reduce depression an improved
mood for some folks enhance cognition
reduce the risk of heart disease and
improve exercise performance just to
name a few and more important than any
of that for the day it's often part of a
daily ritual and without it for a lot of
folks things just seem out of place
I'm just so glad the girl's not
anti-coffee let's make something to eat
all right so she loves granola with
yogurt and maybe toast I like granola
yogurt and also definitely toast so I've
got some really good really ridiculously
good looking like double cream full fat
Greek yogurt this is my favorite
honestly it's so delicious it can be
just eaten all on its own but let's be
real we can make better with some
toppings so we got some yogurt down
let's see what I have left
a little picked over by my Gremlin some
raspberries and blackberries and
blueberries
raspberries are always the first to go
they are just struggles and I have
granola
I'm adding a little more hemp this
actually has some hemp seeds in it but
I'm doubling down because I always have
them on hand anyway
I feel like a little peanut butter would
be nice
just dollop
to mix her in and
I'm like currently obsessed with these
tart berries
a little chewy texture is another really
nice
treat
[Applause]
okay yogurt Bowl down let's make some
toast all right so this is one of my
like favorite new combos we have some
sourdough bread I've mixed some cottage
cheese with some Mascarpone cheese like
hello that is the stuff that you make
tiramisu with yes it is
um smear that on top of my toast because
it just brings me life plus we're adding
some protein in there as well
so good
and whatever kind of fruit you have on
hand I'm gonna do some
banana that's not banana that is a
strawberry I'm gonna do some strawberry
I'm going to do some blueberries yes one
for the mouth
one for the toast
now this is a banana
I have been waiting for this case of
bananas to come ripe all week finally it
is we're gonna have to eat it this
weekend okay A little bit of hemp hurts
to finish that off
as always
and
oh my gosh poppy what do you want what
do you want
we got tons of protein in our Greek
yogurt plus some of the cottage cheese
little mascarpone combo on top we've got
some fiber rich carbs in our granola our
fruit and our bread plus lots of healthy
fats in all the hemp hearts and the nut
butter as well I don't even know which
one I want to start on but I have a
spoon in my hands so I feel like that's
telling me something
that out
that's truly Perfection this is like a
boat
of toast going in ah
this whole club all right now that we've
got a little fuel in the tank let's talk
about Emily's exercise regimen so
according to L magazine Emily is not
much of like a gym girlie and instead
prefers to just be like outside in L.A
like hiking or winding down at a yoga
class once a week I'm not much for yoga
I just have like a really hard time
slowing down but I do have a dog and she
needs to be walked so why don't we go on
outside for a quick little walk move our
bodies get some fresh air and save me
the dog walking fees for the day double
win yes it's pretty gross outside but
the girls still needs a walk it's just
gonna be a short one this was not the
best fit for the day okay lovers let's
talk lunch so according to Harper's
Bazaar Emily will usually have like a
salad or a sandwich for lunch she also
told L magazine that she really like
loves meat and just craves iron so you
would never see her having just like a
plain salad with just like lots of
lettuce and cucumbers and tomatoes on
top so yes meat specifically red meat is
definitely one of the best bioavailable
sources of iron that we have but I don't
honestly eat a lot of beef or red meat
so
I don't have it on hand obviously but I
do have a lot of other really great
building blocks to make an iron rich
salad let's get to work okay
so salads to me are really all about a
combination of Eye of the hiccups so
salads to me
guys I have the hiccups just bear with
me salads to me are a combination of
different colors different textures we
want to make sure that we're getting in
our fiber fat and protein obviously you
don't want me to be pissed when I have a
massive knife in my hands
um but yeah so we're really just aiming
to get whatever colors and flavors that
I have in the fridge and so I'm gonna
just like swing so so I'm just gonna
like throw together a little choppy chop
salad and we're keeping it totally
plant-based but we're trying
and
we're keeping it totally plant-based but
I am trying to lean on all of the more
iron-rich plant-based sources
so
starting with some spinach do I have to
wash this again it's washed
okay
I'm too lazy right now
if you guys want to be pissed at me for
not
quadruple washing this because this is
being triple washed
get at me uh let's do some cabbage for
some color
[Music]
um I also just love a crunchy cabbage
situation oh I made quinoa quinoa is
also a source of
um plant-based iron
sprinkle that around
a little more
okay I got some bell peppers bell
peppers are great because they're going
to add that vitamin C along with the
lemon juice in my dressing and and
that's going to help to increase the
absorption of the non-heme plant-based
iron all right cukes
foreign
I love the baby cubes
they're just so damn cute
a couple pistachios pumpkin seeds
great source of non-heme iron
[Applause]
mm-hmm
I'm feeling like some dates for a little
sweetness and Chew Chew
choo choo choo choo train oh my God I
feel like it's a hazard to have the
hiccups when you are trying to use a
sharp knife because
I can't fully control my body just hope
for the best here folks
Brody I hope you know how to put a limb
in a freezer because I have it all
worked out in my head as most you know
people with anxiety anxiety disorders do
I'm gonna race to the to the to the
freezer right there there's a bag in
there all ready to go we're gonna throw
it into the bag so that it doesn't bleed
out all over my ice and ice cream
obviously and then we're going to call
the cops or 9-1-1 and we're going to
have them quickly retrieve the finger
and likely me as well and then reunite
that's my goal that's my plan that's how
I've worked it out in my head to be
prepared for the worst psycho
all right
some cheese we gotta go we gotta get
cheese I cannot have a salad without
cheese and feta is My Bae this is a very
random salad but it's not gonna feel
random when it's in my mouth
that's what she said oh chickpeas
like where's the protein
like what am I missing
she's much better now now I feel like
this will be more satisfying for me at
least and then I'm gonna make a quick
dressing does not need to be
complicated in fact sometimes I just
don't even bother like mixing it I just
do olive oil and lemon juice or vinegar
right on top that's what we're gonna do
right now I like a lot of lemon
that's great
bye-bye seeds a little bit of olive
Hello beautiful and
finish her off with some salty
puppy
oh you know I feel like this is totally
extra but
not you
have you read this
this is Bomb this is zatar It's a middle
eastern style seasoning made with sesame
seeds oregano sumac and Thyme it's got
like a really nice savory nutty flavor
because of the sesame seeds and it
really does amplify any salad look at
that
foreign
I feel like I nailed that so check this
out we got lots of plant-based sources
of non-heme iron the spinach the
chickpeas we got the pumpkin seeds and
the quinoa really delicious so we're
hitting all the hunger crushing
compounds right here protein in our
quinoa and chickpeas healthy fats in our
nuts and seeds and olive oil tons of
course of fiber from all of our
beautiful colorful veg and because we
have that vitamin C in the lemon juice
and the bell peppers it helps to enhance
the absorption of that plant-based iron
I'm excited to dig it should have got a
bigger bowl
hmm
the dates are really a nice touch nailed
that salad Abby and this salad actually
ends up providing around 7.5 milligrams
of iron which is pretty damn good when
you compare it to a four ounce steak
which provides around two milligrams and
because plant-based sources of iron are
not absorbed as efficiently as
animal-based sources the vitamin C and
the lemon juice and the bell peppers
will help to boost up that iron
absorption all right let's talk about
some snack now according to the New York
Times Emily is apparently obsessed with
turmeric and beet juice I'm not really
sure if those things like always go
together in the juice and like there's a
juice out there in LA that is turmeric
with beets I don't know but I searched
far wide on my ubereats app and I
couldn't find such a juice but this is
Toronto not La so I did get some beet
juice all on its own figured we'd give
that a shot
it's earthy
I don't mind it but I'm not sure that
I'd want to drink like the whole thing
in one go all right well it might not be
your favorite Abby beets and turmeric
both have a number of unique benefits
beets are unique in that they're rich in
natural nitrates which help to dilate
the blood vessels and may play a role in
improving blood pressure cognitive
decline and exercise stamina while
turmeric is rich in antioxidants with
powerful anti-inflammatory properties
which may help to reduce the risk of
heart disease and cancer having said all
that while super nutritious juicing does
strip produce of its beneficial fibers
so it's not likely to keep you satiated
for very long and this is why we're
going to MacGyver some kind of like
smoothie situation using the juice so I
got an apple because like most basic
[ __ ] we went apple picking so we got
a ton of them to get through
those are going in boink boink boink
I've got some of that full fat Greek
yogurt
for some protein hemp hearts
healthy fats and protein I feel like I
need a banana I don't know I just feel
like smoothies don't have the best
texture without a banana there are
banana haters out there and to them I
say you're weird I'm just kidding
I don't want to yuck your young but I
love bananas okay so this is going to be
my base we're going to throw in that
beet juice some natural sweetness
[Music]
this to me seems like a huge upgrade
from a fresh pressed juice we got fiber
in our apples we've got protein in our
Greek yogurt and we got healthy fats in
our hemp hearts so this will keep me
Fuller for way longer than just some
straight up cold pressed juice
hmm
and it tastes a million times better
so I just ran a few errands I answered a
few emails now your girls ready for
dinner Emily girl what are we having
what's your favorite food
you Thai Italian goes on love me some
choices and honestly those three genres
are probably my favorite takeout options
too I just kind of like put them into
constant rotation and according to her
interview with Jimmy Kimmel she
apparently loves her takeout food and I
have a relationship I would love to see
your refrigerator um it's basically
Indian food thai food and preferably
when I'm horizontal in bed
um I've had people come over and watch
me eat and then say like I've lost all
respect for you and I'm a really busy
mom too so let's just say that I have a
very committed and consensual
relationship with my ubereats app I
actually have a whole video on what a
dietitian orders when she does take out
but you can watch right here but today
decisions decisions
I feel like Thai so all right heading my
way smells amazing
let's see what we got she's dripping
all right let's make a meal I couldn't
decide between a lot of these things
obviously this is more than I'm gonna
need to eat in one meal but I like to
have variety and I know that my kiddos
are gonna love it as well so check out
my little Thai food haul all right so we
got some chicken satays for some protein
we've got some rice for some carbs I
always love to get the coconut rice it
just hits different and honestly the
kids love it it's also delicious in
breakfast
so that's my base
I got
a vegetarian curry with some tofu and
lots of veggies in here that goes with
my rice
add a couple little
salad rolls
extra veg
and I can't order Thai food without
getting tom yum soup it is my favorite
thing on any Thai menu
look at that oh it's spicy
spicy
we got veggies we got some tofu in here
we got some mushrooms we got some extra
chicken a spicy broth is just like so
comforting
fun way to get your veg
all right I am craving a little Sunsweet
so let's see what Emily has for dessert
what's your favorite dessert
um I really like sweets
um maybe dark chocolate or pumpkin
cheesecake I also have a sweet tooth and
I love that Emily doesn't seem to like
demonize foods that she loves just
because they have sugar in them between
the dark chocolate and the cheesecake I
am definitely teen cheesecake especially
a nice seasonal pumpkin variety she just
hits different and because I don't
really have the patience to bust out all
my bacon gear today my grocery store did
it for me so we got a little pumpkin New
York style cheesecake as you can see my
husband tried to sneak a slice I caught
him in the act and I told him no I
needed this for today I needed the whole
cake for today but we're gonna have a
slice here's the thing sometimes I I
just want to slice straight up you just
want to have the cheesecake by itself
the Candy by itself a bowl of ice cream
by itself it's a beautiful thing why
change it but this is just me probably
getting older and also just more in tune
with my body but I find often when I
just have just straight up dessert right
before bed I don't feel so good like it
really does mess with my digestion the
next day
um everything slows down and I can take
like a full day for me to recover also I
tend not to sleep as well when I have a
lot of sugar right before bed and
there's not any kind of like protein or
fats to help slow that down
so this is such a tiny slice I feel like
I need more it looks so good together
happy at last I'm gonna add some of this
full fat creamy Greek yogurt this to me
is kind of like whipping cream without
the hassle of having to whip cream plus
it's packed with protein so we love to
see it so lots of that and I've got some
pumpkin seeds here for some healthy fat
um that looks so good all right
I am super excited to dig in this is
what I live for folks we got lots of
protein some Fiber and healthy fats and
we got our beloved cheesecake
that's so good just like that it's so
spicy
well emrata I think we did pretty good
today this was a delicious day of eats I
got some Uber Eats action in there I got
some cheesecake for dessert I got a
beautiful colored salad uh I got a
breakfast that I could literally make
any day of the week and I got it all
without like a ton of pseudoscience and
misinformation
the only thing that sucks is the goddamn
pickups but anyways Emily if you ever
want to hit up another restaurant
together in California I am always down
you seem like a fun girl to have a meal
with and on that note that is all that I
have for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me eat like next subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye I'm
struggling trying not to kick up
[Music]